nach der spektakulären und in der
amerikanischen geschichte einzigartigen
fbi razzia bei einem ehemaligen
präsidenten bei donald trump rätselt
amerika und fragt sich die welt was hat
das fbi gesucht und möglicherweise
gefunden das so wichtig und damit
gefährlich für trump ist das ein
bundesrichter die genehmigung für diese
razzia gibt und ein fbi-chef sie
durchführen lässt er noch von trans
seinen job bekommen hatte womöglich war
diese durchsuchung zukunft entscheidend
für trump der wohl nochmal antreten will
und für joe biden damit auch wohin
steuert amerika unsere wichtigste
schutzmacht
[Musik]
us-präsident der mächtigste mann der
welt schafft es nicht seine jacke
anzuziehen er probiert und probiert und
probiert doch der arm will einfach nicht
in den ärmel die ehefrau des 79-jährigen
muss eingreifen geschafft sind sie einen
wechsel montag nacht blaulicht zuckt
durch die florian ische dunkelheit
beamten sicher das anwesen eine
jahrhundert razzia bei ex-präsident
trump die vereinigten staaten von
amerika groß macht welche die westliche
welt vor ländern wie russland und china
beschützen soll doch momentan scheint
die usa zerlegen sich selbst rückblick
november 2020 beiden gewinnt die us
präsidentschaftswahl nach vier jahren
tram chaos einen neustart doch nur
wenige wochen später der erste eklat
jump anhänger stürmen das capitol
behaupten beiden 26 sei gestohlen wollen
vize präsident mike capps münchen ein
gewaltbereiter mob im wahrzeichen für
demokratie und freiheit
monatelang ermittelt ein
untersuchungsausschuss kommt jetzt zum
ergebnis der damalige präsident donald
trump lockte und stachelte den
gewaltbereiten mob an
anfang der woche dann brattia ein trumps
winter anwesen mar lago in palm beach
fbi-agenten durchsuchen jeden zentimeter
des anwesens
mutmaßlich suchen die ermittler dass
nach seiner abwahl als präsident
verlässt donald trump das weiße haus mit
kistenweise geheimdokumenten die
eigentlich ins nationalarchiv gehören
darunter sollen briefe von barack obama
und sogar nordkoreas diktator kim jong
uns ein verstoß gegen das bundesgesetz
hausdurchsuchung noch in der nacht
reisen jump anhänger nach malaga
unterstützen ihren helden denn trotz
untersuchungsausschuss trotz razzia bei
ihm zu hause genießt trump größte
unterstützung in amerika von wählern und
republikanischen politikern seine macht
ist unangefochtener gilt sogar als
nächster präsidentschaftskandidat wieder
einmal diese streng geheime dokumente
gestohlen hat und versteckt hat das wird
konsequenzen haben ich vermute von
dieser seite aus dass trump kein zweites
mal mehr kandidieren wird möglicherweise
rein aus rechtlichen gründen
und wie läuft's für die demokraten
auch nicht rosig präsident biden gilt
als als schwach und senil sorgt immer
wieder für sport und gelästert kaum eine
pressekonferenz schafft der präsident
ohne versprecher
[Applaus]
kaum ein öffentlicher auftritt ohne
blamage
auch dieser zettel des mächtigsten
mannes der welt sorgte für aufsehen
du betrittst den raum und begrüßt die
teilnehmer
du nimmst deinen platz 1 du verlässt den
raum ist joe biden überhaupt
regierungsfähig
ja absolut ich freue mich auf die
nächsten zwei jahre hat er noch die
energie um amerika nach vorn zu bringen
schon ist die amerikanische
präsidentschaftswahl vorbei beginnt der
kampf um die nächste ein wirrer
präsident und ein straff auffälliger
ex-präsident bühne frei für vize
präsidentin kamera harris nicht ganz die
einstige hoffnung für die amerikanische
politik entwickelt sich immer mehr zum
desaster schwache umfragewerte wenig
aufmerksamkeit kamalla harris ist so
unbeliebt wie kaum ein vizepräsident vor
ihr ich denke der nächste präsident oder
die nächste präsidentin die erste
präsidentin wird das schon hinbekommen
wenn er oder sie eine dem court ist
jemand
der gouverneur also ministerpräsident
von florida
stark im rennen also dass ein
potenzieller kandidat für die
vereinigten staaten von amerika gibt
momentan wenig bewunderung und viel
kopfschütteln es bleibt zu hoffen dass
die großmacht sich bald wieder sammelt
ja dann ordnen wir das doch mal ein mit
unserem amerika korrespondenten herbert
bauernebel wer zuerst mal auf donald
trump schließt sich die schlinge für ihn
da womöglich jetzt endgültig oder kann
er da wieder durchrutschen
es gibt jetzt schon sehr viele
dramatische momente in serie natürlich
in erinnerung bleibt sehr gut dieser
montag wo fbi-agenten mehr als neun
stunden lang sich aufgehalten haben in
seinem privat in seiner privatresidenz
in malaga sogar den kleiderkasten von
ex-first-lady melania durchstöbert haben
wirklich harte polizei tage hier und
jetzt an diesem heutigen tag in new york
war eine aussage angesetzt von donald
trump in einer weiteren untersuchung
über seine erfahrungen seiner ehemaligen
die firmen und hier hat dauernd haben
eigentlich die aussage verweigert das
ist sein gutes recht aber ist natürlich
in der öffentlichkeit auch nicht
besonders überzeugend herübergekommen
aber donald trump hat politisch nach wie
vor chancen seine anhänger halten eisern
zunehmend zu ihm und er hat auch noch
einen sehr guten griff auf die
republikaner partei und es wird erwartet
dass er in den nächsten tagen wochen
monaten seine neue kandidatur
bekanntgeben wird für 2024 schauen wir
auf die beiden herbert er ist alt ist
klar wir haben die partei gesehen gerade
auch in dem bericht andererseits die usa
führen den westen an bei der
unterstützung in der ukraine er hat auch
erfolge vorzuweisen gerade auch das
größte klimaschutzpaket aller zeiten in
den usa durch den senat gebracht
hinter den kulissen scheint joe biden
wirklich eine ganz passable gute arbeit
zu machen denn wie gesagt es gibt diese
erfolge in den letzten tagen und wochen
das hat auch die demokratische partei
wieder ein wenig auf gerechnet aber
natürlich stehen diese bilder dieses
image in der öffentlichkeit wohl einfach
alt wirkt und sehr gebrechlich immer
wieder einen patzer liefert das alles
untergräbt natürlich sein öffentliches
auftreten um auf sein image und auch
seine popularität
und dann dachte man eben kamera harris
ist dann die automatische kandidaten joe
biden abzulösen aber so automatisch
läuft es nicht
erstens müsste schon klar legen dass er
eine zweite amtszeit verzichten wird das
hat er noch nicht getan kammerer harris
hat sich als bitte vizepräsidentin hier
nicht besonders gut in szene gesetzt sie
habe nicht überzeugt ihre wahlchancen
sollte sie antreten 2024 werden für fast
null gehalten also sie hätte keine
chancen demokraten müssten von vorne
beginnen mit einer suche nach neuen
kandidaten und das ist eine große
herausforderung für die partei herbert
bauernebel dank für die anordnung
[Musik]